[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the dave ramsey
show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as the
status
symbol of choice i'm dave ramsey your
host you jump in we'll talk about your
life and your money open phones at
triple eight eight 825-5225
for our first broadcast live of the year
uh chris hogan ramsey personality
best-selling author
joins me today we've got a lot to talk
about of course it is the first of the
year which means all of you
are going to save money get out of debt
stop smoking and lose weight right yep
right there it is right there ready
that's just wrapped up the whole year
wrap it up just be done with it while we
can
that's right and grow hair that's the
last one that's my other goal oh the new
year's resolution
that's right i'm gonna i might do the
other three but i'm not gonna get that
one going i'm
something i don't think you are either
uh you you can touch your head all you
want but i don't think it's gonna work
okay we're not starting off the year
with baldism right okay we're gonna
start off
we gotta start off with an ism we are
for sure but but dave you're right this
is the year 2020 is gone people have
been blaming
god they've been hoping and wishing for
it to go it's gone people
now what we get to do is take more
control than ever yeah
so this is the expectation for we're
going to do better dave
well i'll tell you what this bunch
around here the ramsey bunch has gone to
work
oh yeah we're we're we're in full on
help you mode because you
need some freaking help yep and uh
that's the deal so uh
tuesday night we're gonna be in oklahoma
city that's gonna be fun that's gonna be
a blast
so uh craig groeschel pastor of
lifechurch.tv
uh and a good friend of ours for a long
time has an incredible he's a
world-class leader
arguably america's largest church right
now we're going to be broadcasting a
live stream from there with chris hogan
rachel cruz craig groeschel and me
and the event is called reset because
after last year you need to reset
you need to start again ready set go you
need a white board
blank white board write some stuff on it
and uh you feel like you never save
enough money well we're hitting reset
and ramsey plus is hitting reset they're
going to help you do that
and rachel cruz we've launched a new
book coming out tomorrow know yourself
know your money
she's on book tour and you've seen her
all over america she's on rachel ray
playing out today good morning america
this coming wednesday not to mention
your television set
i promise you the girl is doing a
hundred media hits in the net literally
a hundred and something media hits in
the next three days so uh and they're
all virtual
which kind of means you sort of do them
yeah that's what virtual means
you're sort of doing a media hit you're
sitting your lazy butt at home you
didn't fly to new york she didn't go
anywhere
it's a virtual she's virtually working
dave i feel like she's she's sort of
working she's kind of working
yeah you and i have hit the road before
we've done it we've burned up the trail
we have and she's going to be just she's
just sitting here drinking coffee
so that's how it works with rachel but
you know what i am so pumped for her
this book you all is going to truly dig
in and give you the understanding of why
you handle
money the way that you do and so it's
really incredible it
really is the psychology of it and it's
which then i was going to allow you to
take more control
over your own situation now the beauty
of this reset event because dave is a
genius
you don't have to leave your house you
get a chance to sit right where you are
in footed pajamas your hair curlers or
whatever else you have that i don't own
and you can watch the other hair curlers
visualize that dave
you will burn your corners out just
thinking about it but you get to sit
right where you are
and truly soak in this information this
is the stuff that we have seen over the
last
20 something years of doing this but
also in the last year
we're going to give you the information
you need to really and truly take
control i'm serious
after 2020 have you not had enough yeah
have you had enough i mean really it's
time to change and this is your reset
moment we're going to show you
chris and i are going to walk you out of
debt and into wealth
craig is going to go through and give
you a talk on uh
self-discipline that'll make you
actually want to do it and rachel will
be covering know yourself
know your money and it is an incredible
incredible opportunity oh by the way
it's free
okay so january the 12th at 7 pm our
free reset live stream event will give
you the motivation the guidance you need
to say goodbye to money stress for good
sign up by texting reset
two three three seven eight nine free
one week from tomorrow night january
twelfth at seven pm
reset to three three seven eight nine
it's
free chris hogan rachel cruz dave ramsey
craig groeschel
live from oklahoma city and we're gonna
give you the
first step towards lasting financial
peace
and of course uh you know life church
has some in
studio audiences available uh
appropriately spaced or whatever they do
with that stuff and it's 20 bucks
so it's dadgum near free the gas cost
you more to get over there
and the uh know yourself know your money
book is on sale
and today is the last day at midnight
tonight
it is officially launched and so today's
the last day you get 150
worth of add-ons if you pre-order the
book
today so i recommend you jump onto
daveramsey.com
you'll get the ebook you'll get the
audio book you'll get videos and you'll
get a free
coaching session with our guys with one
of our uh
our ramsey coaches or ramsey preferred
coaches a free coaching call
and so the biggest bonus we've ever
offered with a book so check out know
yourself know your money at
daveramsey.com
check out the reset live event next
tuesday at daveramsey.com or text reset
to 33789
and ramsay plus running the full ramsey
plus membership the whole thing
you want to do a total money reset this
year this is a way to do it
they got a 90-day plan laid out to kick
you off and get you going
and make you win so you know you can win
and if you want to do that
uh you can start ramsey plus for free a
free trial go to daveramsey.com
reset everything's about reset and know
yourself know your money for the next
week and i want you to hear me because
i'm talking to people
on my show that are really following the
path to becoming everyday millionaires
where they already are
the word reset does not necessarily mean
start over
what it does mean though is that you are
going to reset expectations
effort and all of the mindset and focus
you have on moving forward
yeah like like for instance i was i you
know i lost 37 pounds right
yeah then i went to cabo uh-oh and i
came back and i got on scale this
morning
so i have to reset they put weight on
you over there yeah i think
you think they might eat a taco or seven
but yeah that's rude of cabo
it's rude no off button for tacos i'm
just saying all right so
yeah i put on four pounds i went the
wrong way so i got to reset
that's right today it is it's you got to
do it doesn't mean i have to go back and
lose all 37 again
no but 33 of them that's all it's gone i
still got it yeah i got to go
yeah how many times are you gonna lose
30 pounds dave okay so anyway
yeah so finish it up finish it up finish
the goal reset
maybe you're halfway through your debt
snowball this is your reset maybe you're
uh just now starting to get to know your
spouse about money and you get to know
yourself know your money book and that's
a reset
uh maybe you get into ramsey plus and
you go through financial peace
university
again and it's a reset it's okay to have
flunked to the class
a lot of people have take it again come
on back maybe you didn't do
the holidays the right way oh maybe you
would have
a a christmas hangover you're gonna have
a christmas hangover because those bills
are coming in january and february
it's time to reset so this is a great
opportunity for us to get back on the
wagon
tie yourself to the wagon we're going
forward this year
that's what you do even if it's dragging
you that's just a great metaphor tie
yourself to the wagon
all right know yourself know your money
including 150 worth of goodies on sale
through today in the pre-sale don't miss
that
and be sure and text the word reset for
the free
streaming event next tuesday january the
12th with hogan
rachel cruz craig rochelle and me text
the word reset two three three
seven eight nine that's the whole puppy
baby we're here to help you it's that
simple
and most of that's dad gum free or near
it check it out this is the dave ramsey
[Music]
show
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country or have a
better life
the army national guard can help get you
there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits secure your future today
visit nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the dave ramsey
show thank you for joining us
open phones at 825-5225
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two
five nicole is going to start off this
hour in massachusetts hi nicole how are
you
hi dave hi chris happy new year to you
both happy new year to you how can we
help
thank you um so i am 23 with
no debt i'm currently saving for a 20
down payment on a house now uh
my family was really hurt in the 08
crash it led to my parents divorce and
so forth
so that whole experience really left a
scar so my question is
how to best get over this anxiety of
putting so much of my
hard earned money into such a big
purchase
i'm confused why you would have anxiety
over having a smaller payment
no not a smaller payment you would if
you put down a larger amount
you mean more than 20 the more you put
down the lower your payment is right
right and the closer you are to being
debt-free
because having the pay home paid for
would certainly remove anxiety would it
not
i i think it's the anxiety is more um
about having
so much of my wealth in like one app in
one asset
[Music]
if it were paid for what would be the
problem why would that cause you anxiety
if you paid 100 percent cash for the
house
i get i i mean i guess it wouldn't okay
because what it matters is what you're
really your anxiety is not all your
money tied up and when i set your
anxiety's worried about losing
it yeah because you yeah because nicole
you connected
the 08 crash with your parents divorce
and so you know you you're it sounds
like psychologically you're you're
connecting
the money risk along with a past
relationship issue
and two separate things here two totally
different things
and that mindset of you putting down the
twenty percent as they've said the
payment's going to be lower
and then you're also going to be
investing fifteen percent in gross stock
mutual funds
so you're not going to have everything
in one thing you're going to be
diversified
you've got the gross stock mutual funds
and you have your home
so that's going to put you on the path
at 23 years old
i mean seriously that puts you on a path
to become an everyday millionaire in
your early 40s
if you don't deviate okay here's the
thing
let's say that what price range home
what would we be talking about just as
an example
roughly 300 000 okay
let's say that you put 150 down
okay 50 down and you got in trouble
financially what would you do with the
house
lose it a foreclosure
i hope not well let me help you you have
a 300 000 house you owe 150 on you could
sell it right
right but if you owe 298 on it
and you're in trouble and it's worth 300
you can't get out of it you're stuck
okay so the more you put down the more
likelihood you could get rid of it in
the event that there was a major problem
and the lower payment you have so the
easier it would be to float if there's a
major problem
so the point is debt free or moving
towards debt free
is always lower risk not more risk
does that make sense yes yes sir
and uh the thing is that that what chris
pointed out and you pointed it out too
is that the oat crash uh
the stress of that exposed the
weaknesses
in your mom and dad's marriage the
weaknesses were already there
the stress didn't cause it it exposed it
money problems and large amounts of
wealth both
magnify what's already there
they don't make it in other words mean
people don't
rich people don't become mean sometimes
mean people become rich
it's exposed by their wealth their
meanness
but it was there all along if they're
mean
now i know a lot of rich people that
aren't mean don't misunderstand i'm not
calling rich people mean
but i'm saying if they're if you see
someone who gives a lot of money away
they're a philanthropist if they're
wealthy they're just generous
if they're not wealthy but it's the same
thing it's just
exposed more because they got more money
and so the money problems bring out the
stress
or the stress brings out the yeah bring
out the stress and that exposes the
problems
in a relationship it exposes character
things
it did with me when i went broke i mean
my insecurities were magnified because i
was a 28 year old father with a brand
new baby and a toddler
and they were magnified off the chart
when we lost everything and so anything
sharon
said that made me feel like she didn't
respect me made me go
bonkers because my insecurities were
magnified by the money stress does that
make sense
yes and that don't don't confuse that
with how much to put down on a house
those are different things what i'm
gonna do is i'm gonna give you the first
copy i've ever given away of know
yourself know your money
no since it comes out tomorrow yeah i
can start giving away now you sure can
dave so
uh and that really does enter into this
discussion a lot it does because nicole
remember you're also going to follow the
plan
uh if you're already out of debt you're
going to build up a fully funded
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses
boom that's there then you're going to
start to save for the home down payment
baby step 3b and then you're investing
so you're putting yourself on the path
to be able to have peace of mind because
you're working a plan that actually
works
yeah and you're gonna be fine yes you
are and take your time you're 23.
if it takes an extra year or two to get
comfortable with it fine just keep
piling up money
there's very few people that are
debt-free and have a pile of money that
are worried about money
it just doesn't come up much yeah you
know i haven't had people call me up and
go you know
my house is paid for and i'm just
freaked out that one doesn't come up
much
so it's a place to aim towards
tory is with us in springfield missouri
hi tori welcome to dave ramsey show
hi how are you guys doing great how can
we help
so hopefully i can make this make sense
like everyone else that calls i'm
nervous so bear with me
um basically with our stimulus check
we're you know working
the baby sets we're on baby step two
i've been the spender in our
relationship with my husband and
have done dave ish for far too long and
has finally
you know stuck to the past and really
working hard to get this right
um we are on the step you know we're
paying smallest to largest obviously
and the stimulus check is going to be
for 1200 we have a car
and a credit card that are both sitting
at about eleven hundred
um we basically are trying to figure out
which
one to pay off first i kind of think i
know what you're gonna answer is gonna
be
either 1100 it doesn't matter if they're
both 1100 it doesn't matter
which one do you want to pay and i
thought maybe there'd be well the only
difference is the credit card has
interest the card
doesn't it's someone local to us that
basically was helping us out
and which one do you want to pay off
davidson
i mean i would love to have the card
paid for what's your household income
what's your household i probably about
thirty four
thousand my husband works can i stay
home so when are you gonna pay off the
next one if you pay off the car when
you're going with the credit card
two months um well we want to
pile as much money into as we can as
fast as we can
two months two months after the car is
paid for right
that'd be awesome yeah okay i mean can
you do that
i mean um we also have stupid tax
on a couple other things like you need
to sit down to a budget and be able to
answer the question
i'm not the one that needs to answer the
question but you need to answer it for
you you don't know you're running in
circles
okay great but here's the point if you
can pay that car off in two months or
pay the car off and pay the credit card
off in two months or you pay the credit
card off and pay the car off in two
months
this discussion doesn't matter
okay two months from now they're both
gone right out of your life
right yeah and tori not only do you pay
it off the credit card you call it and
close it
down yes like close it down okay
now what dave said how has it been since
you used it
yesterday well
okay you got to pay the credit card off
not the car the
wrong answer the laugh is the wrong
answer you have to pay the credit you're
not you're not in control
yeah you need to get that credit card
out of your life you can't hang out in a
bar if you've got a drinking problem
girl
yeah you're right so you need to cut you
cut that thing up
and close the account and pay it off
with a stimulus check and then pay the
car off in the next two months
and unsubscribe to the email places
where you shop online
they're sending you stuff that's like
crack that's pulling you into those
websites
unsubscribe get your life back today
unsubscribe from the crack
i wish it was that easy it is that easy
with money it is
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the air
happy new year glad you're with us open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five if ever there was a
year we wanted our rear view mirror it
would be the year 2020.
for the first time we could say 2020 is
in hindsight so there we go
yes but there we go a different way of
looking at things but wow
uh hey and next tuesday night we're
gonna be doing this reset event with
chris hogan rachel cruz
me and craig grochelle live from
oklahoma city it's completely free
text the word reset two three three
seven eight nine
and you can be part of that event you'll
be able to watch it from the comfort of
your own
home completely up for free
walking you through how to reset and get
started over for this year
brandon is with us in massachusetts hi
brendan how are you
mr ramsey mr hogan thank you so much and
happy new year to both of you
happy new year how can we help thank you
so the motivation for my call today is
my future family and my future children
so i want to make sure that i love them
well by protecting them right
so i know you recommend 15 to 20-year
term life policies on the path to
becoming self-insured
and my fiance and i are wondering if
25-year policy might be the more
responsible choice
in our particular situation so for some
quick context i'm 26
my fiance is 25 we're getting married
this year
and as part of our premarital counseling
we've
kind of built a vision for what we want
to achieve together and
when we think about how the 20-year term
policy would bring us
we don't think it would quite bring us
to where we would still have
a dependence in our household once we
finish baby step two together
we anticipate 2023 2024
and if we were to take out 20-year
policies once we get married
that wouldn't quite bring us i don't
think to when
our dependents would be out of the house
so would it be wise to
go with a 25-year for both of us dude
you are a planner
you are a planning planner brendan how
old are you again 26.
26. he's already planned out what it
looks like when he's 94. you're amazing
yeah
well done well done congratulations on
your uh on your marriage man that's
awesome
so um do you have are you ill
i am not no you have a history of family
illness that's extreme
and that is part of the issue on my
father's side i would not
exactly say extreme but i could see
rates absolutely rising
if i were to wait a bit longer because
on my father's side there are some
health things that do pop up along the
way
historically like what
oh so high blood pressure
high blood pressure doesn't cause you to
have a rating you having high blood
pressure will cause you to have a rating
so um you know worrying about all this
stuff might do it but um
so here let me tell you the reality of
you can do it if you want to
okay but it won't it won't even do what
you wanted it to do because you're going
to end up having a kid
that's going to not have left home by
the 25 year mark and then you're still
going to come up short
that kind of a thing so what i ended up
doing was i took out when i was your age
we were having babies and i took out
15-year policies
and then i added 15-year policies
periodically
throughout the years and the strange
thing is the difference between the rate
between 26 and 36 is not substantial
and so if three times in the next 10
years you add
more staggered policies
uh you know uh three four years from now
three four years from now three or four
years from now
and or you have other needs as long as
you don't lose your health completely
and become uninsurable that is going to
be much cheaper
because 15-year policies are
substantially cheaper than 25-year
policies number one
and you're not buying insurance that you
don't yet need in anticipation of
worries um
and so i would unless you have a thing
that says okay look
my parents both died of 800 cholesterol
when they were 46 and both of them died
of that and so that's gonna
i probably got that gene which by the
way that's a thing
okay i got a buddy who's got a 700
cholesterol
and his dad died at 50. and so that kind
of stuff that's a thing
and so you you know if you got that
going then yeah you may want to look at
your 25
but if in a normal scenario a typical
scenario where you're going to have a
high blood pressure or a heart attack or
some cancer in extended family that's
not going to keep you from getting
insurance reasonably as long as you stay
fit
and you're not obese and you don't smoke
those are your keys i mean
you know you're going to be fine there
and that's how i did it
and how i honestly would recommend it
but again if you have a
not a vague worry but a valid set of
facts
that says problem problem problem
problem then you'd look at it yeah
and and the other side of this too
brendan is remember as you put this in
place
a 15 or 20 or even if the 25 you're
working to get yourself out of debt
to be able to build wealth so you're the
mindset behind it is your income is
growing but also so is your
opportunity as you move forward so you
know this protection in place the most
important thing is to make sure you get
it on both
you as well as your spouse yeah and you
know what go ahead and price it out now
yeah and ask them to price out a 36 year
old
on 15 year and look at the two and see
if i'm right
and then compare your 15 year rates with
your 25 year rates today
yeah and say do i really want to pay
that much extra for
kids that may come later and i may still
not have even bought a long enough term
to get to them at that point
um so i mean you can't you cannot
there's a certain amount of this you got
to go with the flow and
you know make you know the decision
making is somewhat fluid
the good news is that two of you are
talking about money you're being
unbelievably responsible you're amazing
really i mean you're thinking about
taking care of your spouse your kids
already and you don't have either one
yet yeah and this is just you're a good
man you're gonna do great
don't over think this that's all i'm
saying yeah and the main thing i would
tell people out there if you don't have
life insurance
it is how you say i love you to your
family which is what he said
it is and i want to be a good dad you
want to get that in place i don't want
to hear any more hemming and hauling
chris i'm waiting i'm a little too busy
no no no don't be too busy to love your
family yeah
get it in place and the policy you have
through your job is crap
okay it's not portable if you lose or
leave that job you've left behind the
life insurance
so get a term policy outside of your job
right now seriously don't delay this
anymore let me tell you xander
xander's going to get hit because
there's two things going on that are
going to drive life insurance go to
xander2insurance.com and get your stuff
going
and you need to get it going quick
because there's a lot of people are
afraid kovit is going to mess up the
rates
and there's a lot of people do this at
the first of the year for some reason
like it's new year's resolution to get
life insurance so
it's a good time to jump online and get
it done right now at xanderinsurance.com
good good call man yeah
you're a good man you're gonna do great
and relax
it's not likely mary's in charlotte hey
mary how are you
hi thank you so much for taking my call
sure how can we help
mike my question is um
i've heard you talk about powder butt
syndrome
but i need to hopefully get some advice
on how to approach my 93 year old father
by all counts he's still very healthy he
has built
up some wealth over the years so and
he's still
doing fairly well my brothers and i have
noticed
over the last year maybe a little more
that he is starting to sell off some of
his assets
which is of course his right to do that
what our question really is is how to
approach him and maybe be a little more
involved
because the last property he just sold
we found out he
sold it way under value and
we want to make sure no one's taking
advantage of him because he's a very
nice person
but again we know it's his right to sell
his things
what if you said all of that to him that
it's your right to do whatever you want
you're an unbelievably sharp 93 year old
we did notice this and we love you and
we're concerned we're not worried about
our money
we don't need it we're not worried about
you giving it to us i'm not worried
about that
i'm just worried about you dad how can i
help you
what if he what would he say bug off
well we tried
we didn't come out and say just those
exact words my one brother did say dad
you know we
i want to sit down with you i want to go
over your will we want to know we want
to do
what you want to do because we feel like
maybe this is his way of trying to
protect us and not having to deal with
this
but we made you know the date back in
october we were going to meet with him
my brothers were coming out of town
and then he just kind of said well
uh i wasn't feeling good he he said i'm
not feeling good you better not come
into town so we didn't and then we just
felt like maybe he was avoiding it and
maybe he is
yes i think i would just lean in
continually the way you are with love
you can't make people do stuff that's
right you can't make them do stuff if
if he's not insane or not in competent
uh legally there's nothing you can do
but just love him and just say as an act
of love how can we help you dads right
that's all we want to do we just want to
help you we want it to be the way you
want it to be
how do you want it to be how can we help
you do that and if he won't do that
there's nothing you can do about hunting
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality number
one best-selling author
several times over is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five here on the dave
ramsey show our question of the day
comes from blinds.com they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee it means even if
you screw up
if you mismeasure the blind and it's the
wrong size or you pick the wrong color
and it's ugly
well they will remake your blinds for
free because you screwed up now that's a
satisfaction guarantee
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run all the
time you'll save even more this is an
incredible company use the promo code
ramsey
blinds.com all right today's question
comes from jody in nebraska she says
i have 11 years in the missouri public
schools retirement
and a 403 b from when i lived in kansas
city
i moved to nebraska and now have 12
years in the nebraska public schools
and i'm putting an extra 15 percent into
retirement on top of the 10 percent
the public school puts in my question is
is what do i do with the money
that's in the missouri public school
retirement and the 403 b
do i keep it there or do i move it jody
roll it over you're going to have better
options yourself
than just leaving it there yeah do a
direct transfer rollover to a
traditional ira
with a smart investor pro yep and you
pick some good mutual funds and they'll
outperform
what you were doing there also the 15
percent you're putting into retirement
i probably would include in that i
wouldn't put that all
into the nebraska program i would put
some of that into a personal roth ira
and if you're married two of them
and use up some of the 15 on a personal
roth ira
and that way putting a little less into
the nebraska an
independent freestanding ira uh
will almost i mean with goods with
well-selected mutual funds will always
outperform a uh a public school system
retirement plan
always uh without a doubt just by the
nature of the way they're managed and
the way they're regulated
and so you'll always get a better rate
of return there and you'll end up better
but it doesn't mean not do it at all
it just means that when you want to can
move it move it and when you can put it
in a roth instead and you're 15
you would do that so that's the only
that's the only fine tuning but you're
you're on top of it kid oh you're doing
a good job well done bill is with us
bill's in pittsburgh
happy new year bill almost said merry
christmas came to you
yeah well you know merry christmas happy
new year
that's it how you gentlemen great man
how can we help
so my wife and i are getting ready to
pay off our mortgage and um
the question i have where you hear a lot
of uh of people talk about you know
protecting your home title
so i just wonder what you you guys
thought about you know some kind of uh
protection against
you know people stealing their home
title once you pay off this mortgage the
only thing i would do is something like
a zander insurance id theft
the other the other stuff is a ripoff
it's not needed because it's very
difficult to
uh i mean
to to steal title because it is recorded
at the courthouse and someone would have
to go through a detailed fraudulent
process
which could be easily undone might cost
you a little bit of money with an
attorney or something
and the way to to avoid that is to just
have um
you know xander insurance's identity
theft it covers that
but the people that are out there
pushing just there's two kinds of title
insurance now
there's a title insurance that ensures
your title against fraudulent theft
that one i don't worry about much in
buying a home you insure a title
to ensure that the title itself is clean
and that's title insurance that almost
everyone has bought at one time or
another that's bought a home
and i highly recommend that the other
one i would not buy
instead i would just have good identity
theft yeah bill what's your net worth my
friend
um well the two well you talking with
retirement plans
yeah and everything about uh about
three-quarter mil
okay uh because another thing you might
want to look at now that you're about to
pay off the house is
really looking at uh utilizing a trust
and you know which can also give you
another layer of protection because now
you aren't the owner of the home the
trust is
and so it's it's something in looking
and you know an estate planning
attorney uh and get connected with the
smartvestor pro first and foremost
they'll know
estate planning attorneys in your area
because you're well on your way
to building and if you're thinking about
protecting you want to make sure that
you have all those layers in place
yeah very good question bill so let's
explain exactly what i'm talking about
so that everybody knows
when you buy a home anywhere in the
united states of america
a deed is recorded at the courthouse
public record
right in the name of the owner
and so you could buy it in the name of a
trust you could buy in the name of an
llc
and you could buy it in the name of
chris hogan okay in the name of the
owner
and anyone can look that up it's public
record
and that is the only title the physical
deed
like a car title means nothing with a
car title you need the physical title
to be able to transact you don't need a
physical deed
you need it to have been recorded at the
courthouse
that establishes ownership so the only
way that ownership could be stolen
would be if someone fraudulently created
a sale
that didn't occur gotcha meaning a crook
came in and said okay chris hogan's
house
i'm going to file a deed to sign chris
hogan's name signing
it over to me and then he's quote
unquote
crook has then unquote unquote stolen
the title and recorded that at the
courthouse
okay so there's multiple layers of fraud
theft
and things that have gone on here for
instance almost every i guess every
state i'm
i'm gonna venture and say every state
that deed would have to be notarized
the signature that's right and so when
they signed your name the notary's also
in on it
that's right or that was no or that was
fraudulently done right one of the two
so there's a whole it's a very complex
fraud
versus just stealing someone's identity
and using it to open a credit card i got
you
but it can be done it's being done a
little bit but it's not rampant like
credit card id theft is
id theft is rampant it's a problem but
the actual
theft of a mortgage of the ownership
of the home is highly unusual and
fairly easy to go yeah yeah what me
that's exactly well the identity theft
protection that you talk about dave
uh especially with xander not only does
it protect you but it provides
restoration services
yeah they'll take care of it and that
means they put everything back like it
was because people could spend
hours and days and months battling and
digging through this and if you have the
right protection
you're okay but this one is so bizarre
it is bizarre
that it's easy to prove okay yeah it's
much easier versus someone just opening
a credit card in your name
because if someone opens your credit
card in your name then uh they start
sending you a bill
it shows up on your credit bureau report
right because they stole your identity
right
then you call the credit card company
and go uh that's not me well the first
thing they assume is
is that you just don't pay your bill it
is you
and so you have to go through this whole
thing of being treated like a
a deadbeat that didn't pay your bills in
order to get through the
fraud victim division with the credit
card companies credit card companies are
straight up stupid
but i mean someone actually stealing the
title now you're going to walk into the
register of deeds which in many counties
is an elected position
and it's certainly a political position
at a minimum
and you walk into this governmental
official and go uh somebody's screwing
with your whole system here
yeah and that barney fife is going to
get upset with that and help you fix
that
that's a little different than the
credit card because that's why you have
to show your id
as something gets notarized and so don't
ever if even if a friend's a notary
don't ever ask them to
to notarize anything without you having
your id they have to put that in their
logbook that's how they protect
themselves
yeah and again it's a very complex form
of fraud and i wouldn't worry about it i
have not bought that on myself i own a
bunch of property
and um you know it's all in llc's and
trusts and so forth i don't have in my
personal name
but none of my properties have never run
into that
type of title insurance if that came up
i would just use some money
and or xander was under insurance and i
would just go punch them in the nose and
figure it out and you know it gets
straightened out it's just really
it's not it's a it's a fairly complex
thing and so it makes it very easy to
undo
right this is simply not me boy is a lot
of stupid out there
well if people would work half as hard
at working as they do at stealing
they'd be rich that's exactly you know
some of these people just if you just
work
at your job that hard you wouldn't have
to steal i mean it's unbelievable
there's i mean if they use all that
intelligence i mean you think about all
you have to go through to be do that
level of thought
yeah you know for for oh well that's it
so but that's how it all works and
that's one of the reasons you get zander
insurance but that one's coming up
the other one that's coming up more
often than that one is is the um
medical you know there's a the
equivalent of a credit bureau for all
your medical records
and people are getting in and tampering
with people's medical records under id
theft xander's covering that too
but uh it's just it's like yeah man
people go get a job i mean it's really
you know just spend all your time
stealing something it's unbelievable
wow oh well you and i will never be out
of business
nope we got people to help me you jenny
craig we got a lot a lot of work to do
that puts us out of the dave ramsey show
in the books
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the dave ramsey show where debt is
dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has
taken the place of the bmw as the status
symbol of choice thank you for joining
us america chris hogan ramsey
personality
is my co-host today as we take your
questions about your life
and your money open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five
forty-one percent of americans make new
year's goals and resolutions
only eight percent end up keeping them
sixty percent already threw in the towel
before they started apparently what
and here's what we know we know that
people don't set goals because they
don't think they can hit them
right i mean eight percent
only only eight i mean that's why we
call people successes
golly they're successful yeah i mean
being able to stick to it to be able to
follow up and i've said this
a dream is a goal without a plan
it's a wish if you don't have a plan and
so what do you
want to dream yeah you do have to dream
it's something but you don't want to be
a dreamer
no no no no which by definition is
someone that does not ever implement any
freaking hard work to do the drink
that's right they just bump their gums
and talk about it would be nice one day
yeah like if your daughter comes home
and says i'm dating a dreamer you go oh
god they're gonna live in the basement
that yeah no they're gonna live in the
basement it's gonna work out
this ain't the one honey this ain't the
one oh
yeah so i mean you want to be dreaming
but dream needs to
uh get the clouds blown off of it and
put some work clothes on and knock
things out so
i always wanted to dot dot okay then
this is your year
yeah okay what is it you're gonna do
and here's what we do know we do know
that we all
even though it's unpopular and
politically incorrect to talk about
winning versus losing we all admire
people who achieve their goals we call
them successes
now sometimes people we only you know
it's the tall poppy syndrome as the
australians call it where we
stand them up only in order to knock
them down like we want everybody to be
successful but as soon as they are we
have to do something to make sure that
they're not but uh and because some of
them are jerks but that's but
you know some people that are successes
but by and large people that are
successful have worked very very hard to
get there
they've done things that other people
wouldn't do
so i mean if you want to throw a
football like peyton manning if you want
to hit a golf ball
you know like rory or tiger right it
requires hitting that swinging that club
until your hands bleed
it's not like you go out there three
hours on saturday and go up there it is
i'm just a natural
you know it requires freaking work right
yeah it really does
so you know it's you and
and yet people want to say oh well he
didn't earn that or she didn't earn that
that's not really any of your business
to start with but let's work on you
how can you be successful and it is by
setting goals
it really is and dave you know i have
been here a part of this company
going on 16 years and goals is a topic
we've taught on a lot especially inside
of entre leadership
where we're working with business owners
business leaders
people that are helping other people
achieve
and so a part of that we have found that
there are five
things that your goals need to be number
one
specific you've got to be clearly drawn
in
into what it is you're wanting to
accomplish and you need to be very
specific number two it needs to be
measurable
you need to look to see am i making
progress toward this or am i not
right and so i want to lose weight not
good enough
no because that is measurable right but
it's not specific
right i want to lose 30 pounds ah now we
have measurable that's right we have the
first two
yeah and we have specific okay i want to
make more money won't work
nope how much more yeah
measurable and specific i want to make a
hundred thousand dollars when
over 15 years or this year what's your
goal
what you're aiming at that's right and
then it brings the next thing in which
dave was talking about a time limit
so you've got to have a period of time
that you're saying i'm going to achieve
this
by this so as soon as you do that the
math kicks in
those three things oh it's specific it's
measurable has a time limit i will lose
30 pounds
when over 15 years right or over 15 days
probably not going to happen or let's
say over 90 days okay if you say 30
pounds over 90 days everybody do the
math with me right quick 10 pounds a
month
two and a half pounds a week increase
your water intake increase your sweat
level
at least 30 minutes a day do some
pushing ladies push backs and push ups
push-ups push away quit eating the white
stuff the breads and the rices i mean we
know what to do you don't need oprah you
know what to do
and you're gonna go do it right and so
this is how you lose weight you eat less
you exercise more
day and so and that and
you can look at it and go after a week
i'm up five pounds instead of down two
and a half i don't think i'm heading
towards my goal
because it's measurable it's specific
and it's broken down then into
incremental
things i want to write a book okay i'm
going to do 12 chapters i'll be a
chapter a month for a year maybe two
chapters a month for six months
you've done it you're moving and so
you've got specific measurable time
limit
in writing this was the game changer for
me
uh even back in college days our coach
would have us write down what are you
going to do in this upcoming ball game
yeah
number of tackles yeah write it down how
many tackles was your
number was the highest number tackles
you in the game oh i think 14 or 15.
did you just lie no really no no no
because i put it down and that little
man would read the goal
and if you didn't hit it you felt
accountable that means people you
you were coming over the middle of the
middle linebacker hitting somebody i was
doing things 14 15 times that scares the
crap out of me i'm just saying
made my heart happen it makes me it
makes me scared i'm going to scoot over
here
but listen here so the specific
measurable have a time limit
in writing and this last one is huge
it's got to be yours
and as we talk about this other people
can have goals and thoughts and my wife
wants me to lose weight
it's not going to work your your dad
wants you to become a pastor okay ain't
gonna work
i don't i don't wanna go to your church
it's gotta be yours and when it matters
to you
i'm gonna tell you something i talked to
people dave on my show about this
the secret to setting goals i want you
to identify
whose wins when you win like think about
it if you get healthier your kids win
because you're better but what are you
going to sacrifice in order to get that
win you know one of my pastors did the
opposite he's got written in the front
of his bible
who would be negatively affected if he
ever fell
in the front of his bible he reads that
every day the number of lives i would
destroy
if i make bad decisions and this is the
opposite this is if i make good
decisions
i can change my family tree that's right
i can give to this charity
i can give to this ministry i can grow a
business and
give people jobs i can if i win this is
what happens yeah
and yeah that write down who's gonna
who's gonna be affected when you win
that's powerful no it does and it
changes the mindset around it
and uh it's really important and dave i
know you've also been around zigg for
many years
i had an opportunity to meet him through
you uh that man was a game changer but
uh he talks about seven areas
uh that we call the wheel of life
financial goals intellectual goals
family goals spiritual goals physical
goals career goals and social goals
and they are all um intermingled hmm
you can't just you know if you win it
finances and lose your family you missed
it
if you win at family and you're all
broke because you never work but
everybody's really nurtured
then um that's probably not a good plan
either right and
so i mean if you win at your work and
your family but you let your
physique get completely out of control
right then you've lost i mean so these
things are intermingled spiritual goals
hey
america watch them in every area hey
dave which area gives you the most
challenge and then the seven
social and seriously sharon says if i
wasn't married to her i wouldn't have
friends
that's not true you just would have i
said she said it i didn't say it's true
there you go it's been the same for 16
years it just makes my heart
happy to ask him yeah but you coming
across the middle 14 times and a dadgum
game scares the crap out of me i'm just
saying
all right folks set some goals specific
measurable have a time limit and in
writing and most importantly they need
to be your goals
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters
with easy online ordering free shipping
and a guaranteed perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five fairfax
virginia is with us nana's on the line
hi nana how are you
hi dave how thanks for taking my call um
i'm on baby step four
i'm currently renting an apartment have
about maybe forty two thousand dollars
saved up in my savings account by a
house
um while i am renting i'm still putting
money into the house savings and i
recently opened up an american mutual
fund account
i'm a little conflicted because i live
in the dc maryland virginia metropolitan
area which is extremely expensive
i'm not thinking about moving to a
thousand about a year or two to purchase
a home
would you suggest that i buy in this
area now or
wait until i move down south in a few
years to buy
a home i know how you are about
purchasing versus renting so
well if you're not going to be there but
a couple of years i'd probably wait
okay you could you could get stuck i
mean you could buy a home in this white
hot real estate market right now
and the market slows down two years from
now when you're ready to move and you
couldn't get out of it
and so um that short a window how old
are you
i am 31. okay well you got plenty of
time
the point is to become a homeowner over
some time
and we don't want to be renting until
we're 94. that's a bad plan
financially mathematically but if you
give up a year or two
in order to not get stuck in something
uh i'm fine with that where are you
thinking about living where you think
about ending up
um so i worked for the federal
government um with hhs and i was
thinking about relocating to
the atlanta area to work for the cdc um
so
who i was just listening to about smart
goals so i kind of have like my smart
goals
in order and i'm hoping that you know in
that time period i can move down to
atlanta where the homes are
a little bit cheaper by then um right
now i'm saying about 900 to a thousand
dollars a month into my house savings
account
um my emergency savings it's already
capped um so by then i'll probably have
an additional like maybe
20 grand well here's the thing i'm
curious um
i don't know how this stuff works in
your world why can't you do it now
um i guess it's just more so i'm
paralyzed by fear
um i'm just afraid to buy a house that's
the biggest purchase i've ever made no
i'm talking about move to atlanta
oh move to atlanta um because i just got
my federal
um job back in august so i'm still about
four or five months
into it and i'm kind of waiting to get a
higher grade
um before i can start applying for
positions within the cdc okay
gotcha well i listen i love the the
mindset that you have and the level of
focus
that you have you've got time frames you
know you're trying to move up
uh in class and then be able to transfer
but i would tell you this when you get
ready to move to atlanta i think it's an
excellent idea
for you to go there and rent for a few
months get a lay of the land
understand kind of the zones where to
live where to avoid and figure out where
it is you want to be
and then when you are ready to make that
decision to to be somewhere
for three years or more then i think
you're ready to buy
yeah so i think i'd move to atlanta as
soon as your career allows you to not
when you're ready to buy
yeah yeah and if you rent it there for a
little while the rent will be cheaper
that's right and maybe depending on
where you locate in atlanta but
um if you're careful about it it should
be cheaper and that will enable you to
buy
faster but you don't have to buy
simultaneous with the move
and a matter of fact i'd get down there
sooner rather than later if i were in
your shoes if that's the long-term goal
i wouldn't put it off but you got to get
your grade up i understand that and um
you know to be able to make the move
that you're talking about that within
the career structure of what you're
doing which i know nothing about so
good luck with that all right greg's
with us in uh california hi greg welcome
to the dave ramsey show
hey thank you for taking my call sure
what's up so um
my beginning pandemic my wife lost her
job
and then i was put on reduced pay and
hours
and throughout the season we've been
able to save money
and get to about 30 000 saved
but we do have a 15 000 401k loan
and what we're trying to do because
we're kind of hesitant to pay it
mainly because my job they just
furloughed more general managers
but i was one of the ones that wasn't so
we're trying to determine if
we're holding backers or more fearful or
should we pay it
to get rid of that debt even though we
have a risk is my job may be gone
well how real is that risk greg like uh
are they is this sounds kind of real
yeah i mean is it something that can
happen in the next few months
well they're telling us they're
confident i'm a movie theater general
manager
so they're confident that we'll
eventually reopen
we just don't know when right so in
california
right especially in california well
here's here's why i'm asking this i feel
you your resume needs to get out
and be dusted up and prepared because
here's the downside
with the 401k loan if you do lose that
job
you'll have 60 to 90 days before that
401k loan
is due and payable that's correct so
mindset wise if i'm you i would be
dusting off my resume
to really start to learn man why is your
wife looking for work as well she found
something
um no we had her not look because our
children have some
therapies and some health issues that
have required her to really focus on
them while
my schedule is actually deeped up on
time because i travel a lot more
to watch other theaters
okay so you're more of a regional
manager type at this stage is that what
you're saying
you're more than more than one theater
is that what you're saying
yeah only because right now they
furloughed a lot of the general managers
having one gm multi-check multiples here
okay but you're really just looking at
closed buildings right now right
oh absolutely yes oh lord i'm sorry
oh what a disaster um
yeah i i think i'm with chris i you know
here's the thing
you stop all baby steps push pause and
pile up cash
if a storm is coming now we have to
define and that's what chris and i are
doing talking to you is trying to define
how what's the probability that this
hurricane is going to affect your home
okay if i'm in nashville and it's going
to hit new orleans i'm probably going to
be okay
right but in your case you got it you
got winds coming right at you it sounds
like
number one you're in an industry that's
really struggling
uh and it's gonna struggle with covid
more than a lot of other industries i
mean like a live event type setting i
mean it's a
this is a very difficult thing to reopen
um and number two you're in freaking
california which has completely lost its
mind
and so um uh and
you know politically you've got all
kinds of problems
in terms of reopening and so if i'm you
i'm pretty scared for my job
so no i wouldn't pay that off today i'd
pile up cash as high as you can pilot i
would have everybody working that could
work
and let's really get the plywood over
the windows and
all of you be looking for jobs and all
of you get your resumes dusted off
and all of you have a plan for if this
doesn't go well
now if the storm passes
and it wasn't a direct hit we take the
plywood off the windows and we start
again right
okay but right now i i don't i don't see
that storm passing in the next six
months
in your setting or three months anyway
yeah i could be wrong i mean maybe they
recall newsome and they open up the
whole state but i
doubt it i don't i don't i don't know
anything about it i'm just watching from
the outside like everybody else going oh
my goodness what a mess
and so um yeah uh
well yeah and dave like you said the
piling up cash
let's talk there's no doubt there's not
a downside to it and here's the deal
this wasn't found money like the plan is
is when the storm passes you then
unpause and keep working the steps pay
it off
immediately yeah so you're not once you
are secure in your job that's right
and or the new job right you pay off
that 401k loan immediately
with the cashless laying there and you
push play again and you go finish your
baby steps that's right you're good
point chris
that's the main thing you want to do it
is it really is take care of the four
walls
food shelter clothing transportation
utility pile up cash right
be ready for the big bad wolf to huff
and puff right be the third be the third
pig in the brick house right
get the four walls built and then go
from there
and and so the big bad wolf wanders off
now we can come back out we can do
you know the shutters are open we can be
back in the sunshine
we can do stuff again and um got to
re-evaluate you poor folks man i'm so
sorry for you
i mean we don't have i don't think we
have theaters open here do we no yeah i
think we did
no there we did they probably just
closed them again i don't know i can't
keep up with what they're doing but
it's like i mean it's a it's an industry
that was in trouble anyway netflix is
destroying them
yeah and so they were hurting already
and then they're just
politically just finished a great
american icon
the movie theater this is the dave
ramsey show
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country or have a
better life
the army national guard can help get you
there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight
eight two five five two two five
a couple of big things happening it is
new year's happy new year
and it's time to reset a lot of you
after last year go
i really need to rethink this money
stuff i've not been doing it as well as
i
should well if that's you then ramsay
plus is ready and it has a
free trial to help you walk through
and they've got a 90 day program right
now to help you with some quick wins
and help you make some real progress
quickly
on your debt and it's really the team
over there has done a wonderful job i'm
so proud of them
so go to ramsey plus if you want it for
free go to daveramsey.com
reset and you can take on a free trial
today is the last day to pre-order
rachel cruz's brand new book it hit
stores tomorrow
know yourself know your money 150 worth
of free bonus items
along with the hardcover book of course
all for just
20 bucks if you order it tomorrow you'll
get a book
which is worth 20 bucks absolutely oh
without a doubt but you're missing out
on it if you don't go into it right now
by midnight tonight
and the big deal is next tuesday night
you and i chris hogan and i
rachel cruz craig groeschel live from
oklahoma city from lifechurch.tv are
going to be doing
a live free streamed event
called reset to get you ready to reset
for the new year
i am so excited i mean again
talking about 2020 being behind us and
now moving forward in 2021
giving people the opportunity to have
the information to be able to grow
forward
i'm telling you i'm very excited for
this event i want you all to mark
your calendar january 12th 7 p.m
and again just text this right now text
reset to 33789 that way you rsvp
and you've got a spot right in your home
to watch us free
it is free tuesday night seven o'clock
one week from tomorrow be there january
the 12th
text reset to three three seven eight
nine we're going to walk you through the
plan
some of you already know the plan but
you need a reset and rachel's of course
going to talk about know yourself know
your money
and of course doctor or a doctor like he
may be a doctor but craig groschel
pastor craig
is going to be talking he did a talk on
discipline that was
absolutely made me want to be more
disciplined it'll do the same for you
and he's going to do that talk for us so
pretty cool stuff
if you're in the oklahoma city in your
area and you want to be in the live
in the live audience appropriately
spaced life church is going to have our
studio audience
seating is extremely limited uh like
very
very very limited this could be a
handful of people but they're 20 bucks
and they're available at daveramsey.com
events make sure you plan to come out if
you're in the oklahoma city area yeah
now listen to me
all this stuff the live stream is going
to be amazing put that on your calendar
january 12th
but listen with rachel's book uh know
yourself
know your money you've got to pre-order
this thing you've got an opportunity to
have a coaching session
with the financial coach it's like
working with your own personal financial
trainer
and so get this thing ordered right now
before the pre-sale goes away
and you've got many options ahead of you
edgar is in chicago hi edgar welcome to
the dave ramsey show
hi dave and chris happy new year happy
new year how can we help
i have a question about a subordinate
loan i um i got divorced in 2012
after i find i found out that my house
was in foreclosure
and she stole the mortgage money from
2011.
um so i was able to get a loan
notification
and something that was called a
supporting loan i didn't know anything
about it
for 54 000 i was able to save my house
now i would like to refinance and um
the supporting loan is hunting me a
little bit
um i would like to you know try to get
to a 15-year conventional
instead of a 30-year fha as i have now
uh so i'm trying to figure out what to
do with this thing and how to go
about it well essentially what a
subordinate loan is all subordinate
means is
it's behind the other mortgage and so a
subordinate loan in this case is a
second
mortgage or a third mortgage it's
probably just a second mortgage you have
a first mortgage on there from the
original loan
all the back payments when you got
behind became a new
second mortgage it's it works exactly
the same mathematically edgar as if
you've taken out a home equity loan
to catch up your payments okay that's
how it's working okay
so you got 54 000 there what's your
first
balance my first is 146 right now
because that 54 is on a zero percent
and pay it off after the 30 years is
over yeah but it's going to be gone if
you refinance
yeah so you owe you owe 200 000 on your
home what's your home worth
uh 285 okay so you can refinance
a 200 000 first mortgage and it pays off
both the first and the subordinate
and that's the only thing that's going
to work they're not going to
remain subordinate to a new mortgage
after you refinance that was a favor
they did you because of the
the screwed up mess you got in yeah okay
okay
so so it's worth going into a 15-year
conventional possibly at two percent or
two point nine percent
instead of being in the thirty year fha
three point six percent
on 146 and zero on 54. yes
okay so it'll be on 200 even just about
200 yep yeah
yeah but the point is i mean if you
figure out that the total interest paid
on the way you're paying it now
is 3.6 on uh 146
and the total interest charge might be 3
or 2.9 or something on 200
but you've also cleaned up your mess
that's where you don't have this thing
hanging over your head this knife
hanging over your head
out there from the past mess and all
that stuff yeah and
i i would i would do it i would get
refinanced immediately if you can
explain
even if it costs a slight amount more
just to smooth everything out
and it's going to be again that past
payment history bumps and all that'll be
behind you because you've moved forward
with a new loan
that's exactly what i would do having
been in this industry for many years
this is the better route good question
ed yeah good question
okay teaching moment um subordinate if
you have a subordinate at work
it's someone that's under you correct on
the org chart
right uh if uh if you're talking about
i am so-and-so subordinate i am after
him or whether
okay subordinates the same thing on a
mortgage the first
mortgage date when when you file a deed
of trust that's
our mortgage depending on the state at
the courthouse
the date that it's recorded makes it
what it is
so the first one the fir the earliest
date the oldest
date is the first mortgage correct
you can't just name something first
mortgage and call it first market that's
right
okay that's right the next one that is
recorded is
the second one that is recorded it is
subordinate to the first
yep and it's called a second mortgage so
if you record one and five years later
you record another
by definition the the second one you did
is the second mortgage and the third
mortgage
and the fourth mortgage and so on and
even if um
someone files a lawsuit against you and
takes a lien on the property they don't
jump in front of the mortgages they land
on that date
timeline they might be in sixth position
if you've been sued a bunch
that's right you know they might be in
second position if you've never been
sued at all
other than your first mortgage is in
place that's right and so
the the we used to call it the race to
the courthouse that's how title is done
the first one to record the deed is in
first
position and so uh anything after that
is
by definition subordinate and that's
where that name comes from
it doesn't really mean anything except
that it's
not first that's right we don't know if
it could be second it could be third it
could be four
in his case i'm pretty dead i'm sure
it's second i'm pretty good i'm sure
there's nothing else on there but those
two things
from what he's describing that's right
so that story is a very clean story but
yeah
and the other one dave that i'd like to
clarify with people is this whole
ex-home equity line of credit
see people don't view those and the bank
was very smart when they brought those
on because they don't call them a
mortgage when in fact they are that's
exactly right
it is a second it is a third or third
mortgage
mortgage but they never call it a
mortgage and so it became this
very fashionable marketing tool to
yes rich people have lines of credit now
i have a line of credit now you have a
mortgage
on your property and so just being aware
of that and we don't want to fall for
those antics anymore
we're gonna count yeah yeah home equity
lines of credit yeah home equity loans
are mortgages on your freaking house
to buy a couch what's wrong with you
no no no no more listen it was a line of
credit and i'm sophisticated
oh brother yes yes this is the dave
[Music]
ramsey
foreign
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight 825-5225
you jump in we'll talk about your life
and your money it's a free call
you jump in justin is with us justin's
in orlando hi justin welcome to the dave
ramsey show
hi dave thank you for having me sure
what's up
um just want to call in with a quick
question get your your advice and your
input
i'll explain my scenario real quick i am
an elementary school physical education
teacher
i've been teaching now for 11 years and
it's been a wonderful
um career path for my family and it
enabled me to have a wonderful schedule
with my children
and my wife and i have three young boys
under the age of eight
um long story short my wife and i found
your program right before we got married
and um had followed it um as the best we
could all throughout the
years we've been married now for about
nine years um
started off you know working the baby
steps working the dead snowball and
now we're in a position where i feel
like we
are very very blessed um god has
definitely provided and your program
has has been amazing um
my situation i'm in now is when we were
working the baby steps i kind of took
your your joke of showing the
dog on craigslist and the cat on on ebay
to heart and started selling everything
on ebay
until we sold out of all of our own
possessions and i you know took it a
little bit further and started getting
into wholesaling and
little known to me kind of stumble upon
a business
i've been doing it now for eight
actually sorry about
nine nine and a half years and this last
year um has been my most lucrative in
terms of the business in terms of the
business
it's grown each year and it's honest
honestly my passion my dream
um it's enabled my wife to to quit her
job her career job of um
working in sports technology and she's
now a stay-at-home mom
and i worked hard to be able to get that
done for her and now i'm kind of at the
point where
i'm itching to um to pursue my
my passion in terms of being a full-time
e-commerce seller as well
wow i just want to get your thoughts on
if it made sense in
if i was making a wise sound decision
and doing so wow
justin's don't leave us hanging how much
did you make
this past year my gross income was 120
000
and i netted about 70. okay and what do
you make at your day job
my day job as a teacher i make 44 000
before taxes
okay and is your lifestyle what's your
lifestyle set up on you're out of debt
you have an emergency fund right
we're out of debt um i have an emergency
fund fully funded of about fifty
thousand dollars
our mortgage and house is completely
paid off i live in a
300 thousand dollar 310 000 house
and it's paid for it's completely paid
for yes sir
you are a rock star brother the ball so
you can live on 70 000 right
i i definitely think so absolutely um
i'm very conservative and i think not
that it scares me i know
um i have enough confidence in myself
but you know
going scary a lot of my life to um
to becoming a teacher and going in a
completely different direction
um but you obviously have been doing
this a while this is not a lark this
isn't something for one year you did and
you got all pumped up
uh this is something you gradually grown
over nine and a half years
and it's a legitimate serious business
now
right yes sir okay uh and it's what you
want to do you enjoy it
absolutely i love it okay so when are
you turning in your resignation
well um i i'm spoken with my wife and
and i agree with her she she feels that
um i should
you know finish the year teaching okay
go into a
headstrong you know beginning of next
school year after i would quit over the
summer
you know going into the next school year
yeah
that was kind of you know her suggestion
i and i value it you know i'm i
i'm well respected in my job and want to
leave on a good term absolutely and you
know finishing out the school year is
kind of a classy thing to do
no harm no foul you can do that and it
you'll have a lot of energy just knowing
that it's coming to an end that's right
sure even though it feels like it's a
long way away but it's only five months
and so right you know um i would go
ahead and let them know that they
when the school year wraps up you are
and i would get on with my business
uh yeah and i think this i think you
will always
be a teacher
it just may not be at that location in
the elementary school you might teach
someone how to do ebay stuff you might
teach
uh sunday school at your church i don't
know what it is but i think you're a
teacher too
yeah by the way i am i love teaching
yeah by the way i'm a teacher
it's what i do and i love teaching it's
one of my gifts
as a matter of fact i'm a gifted teacher
a lot of things i'm not gifted at but
that one i am
and so that's uh that's who you are
and it does not have to manifest itself
as
a uh elementary pe teacher no and justin
i'm going to tell you buddy
congratulations very very very very well
done
remember the principles that got you
here is what i want to leave you with
uh meaning the mindset of looking at and
seeing debt for what it is
it's not a tool it's a threat and so
even as you look to grow in your
business
again please don't let your guard down
please don't think that you suddenly
have to hit a grand slam
when you've been hitting base singles
and you've been winning
yeah so remember those things and don't
deviate from your plan young man you're
on the ball
four yards and a cloud of dust get you
get you a uh a first down every three
yeah and you don't have to worry about
it just you don't have to you don't have
to put the ball at risk
and that's all that's all we're trying
to do here just it's ball protection
just
just finish out you're doing very very
well and jump onto the entree leadership
stuff if you haven't
and get plugged into the um in the
entree leadership elite and get plugged
into some groups of some of the other
sellers we've got on there they're doing
really well
you can learn a lot from each other as
you go jordan is with us jordan is in
effingham illinois hi jordan welcome to
the dave ramsey show
hey mr ramsey hey mr hogan how are you
guys today great man how can we help
thanks for taking my call hey i am kind
of like that last guy that called i'm
also a teacher
and not in the same situation as him but
um one day hope to be
so today i'm calling because i am on my
last house payment this next month
and i got a loan without interest from a
mom and i know you told me not to do
that but i did it before
i knew you guys and so i'm just telling
those that are out there in the same
situation are about to make that mistake
don't do it
the borrower's slave to the lender as
you guys say and um
you just it just puts a terror in a
relationship that doesn't need to be
there
so now i'm in another situation that's
probably going to tear a relationship
apart
for a short bit hopefully it'll heal but
um
after i pay my last house payment my mom
gave me the loan and she did not want me
to pay for the shed
originally i thought that was because
she was protecting me thinking my house
i owed so much my house and that was
like an overwhelming feeling for me well
now i think it's more that she wants to
own the shed so she can store a boat in
it
um however my it's on my land and it's
under on my deeds so
it's not really hers i just need to pay
her for it that's the 35
000 that i owe her for it and so
um she's wanting to now give it to me
for free
um as a gift i'm the oldest of five uh
five four siblings on the block there's
strings attached
yeah i don't want that to tear a
relationship with martial you're afraid
if it's not really a gift
it's like i want to be a part owner in a
sense
uh yeah possibly i don't i mean she's
been pretty good
originally it was kind of a tear in our
relationship when she gave us alone we
started paying it off so fast
that she hasn't really been an issue but
now i feel like this might be her last
control piece um and so we don't want to
do that my wife and i
talked about it um and i just i feel
like an idiot for making that call and
making that ask and people are probably
like why don't you just take it but
no it's not there's too many listen it's
not a gift if there's any strings
attached and you feel control and other
issues are going to pop up
and she's going to file some uh be a
travel agent for guilt trips every time
she wants to use your shed
yeah jordan you were wise and you were
wise
january i'll have it paid off anyway so
it's really just another year of debt
yeah let's go ahead and pay it off
i agree with you yeah and uh it also
complicates the estate plan if you got
five siblings you know she gave you 35
000 she didn't give anybody else right
yeah
well and she said she's going to give
them something but i don't know if
that's going to be fair or what that's
going to look like so i don't want to
yeah
take a chance on that yeah mom just for
the cleanliness of your estate i think
it's better if i just go ahead and pay
you off
and i'm gonna go ahead and do that this
year and please don't take offense i'm
just trying to do the right thing and i
just want you to be
i just want to have this very simple
thing where there's no transaction
between you and i except
mother and son yeah that's what the mom
says my mom says
or my wife says well your mom's always
gonna love you so if you make her mad
it's okay but if your parent if your
brothers and sisters are mad at you they
may never forgive you so
well if they're mad at you for no reason
that's their problem too so
but i i wouldn't worry about them that's
not they didn't come up in this
discussion until the last sentence but
um i still would pay it off because i
think there's a lot of crap flying in
the air here i can
smell it i agree hey thanks for the call
brother happy new year everybody
that puts this hour of the dave ramsey
show in the books
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the dave ramsey
show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice my
co-host today on the air chris hogan
ramsey personality number one
best-selling author of the book everyday
millionaires and the book retire
inspired both number ones we're taking
your calls at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple
a five eight eight two five
five two two five my mind wandered off
chris
it wandered off because i was thinking
you got two best sellers and i think
we're getting ready to have another one
here with rachel cruz's new book
know yourself know your money it
launches tomorrow yep
and uh so today's the last day you can
pre-order it and get the deal
that's right and inside of that deal not
only do you get all the extras of rachel
the audiobook the e-book
but you get something really cool you're
going to get a lot of
quizzes and access to information to
help you but the thing that i think is
awesome is you're going to have an
opportunity to meet with a financial
coach
that's like working with your own
personal trainer on the financial
side which is amazing you get a chance
to ask the questions you've always
wondered
about your specific situation it's just
a unique opportunity
that's all free it's all free if you buy
the book today and so
get the book like don't don't wait
because it's all going away
come tomorrow so this is the last chance
so here's the thing know yourself know
your money we know that personal finance
is 80
behavior and this deals with the
behavior it's only 20
had knowledge the problem is with your
money's not the math
the problem with my money is not the
math it's the guy in my mirror
and so what motivates the guy or the gal
in your mirror what is it that
messes you up what is it that holds you
back what is it that keeps you stuck
what is it that makes you afraid what is
it that makes you brave and effective
and when you know yourself
in regards to how you look at money why
you
why do i do that with money you ask
yourself when you and you get those
questions answered with know yourself
know your money
it puts you in a position to control and
change the behaviors
to it and to understand the behaviors of
your spouse yeah
and this is why she thinks that way she
grew up in a house like that
and rachel goes through every bit of
that this book is heavily researched it
is very well done know yourself know
your money
at daveramsey.com or anywhere great
books are sold and it's part of our new
year's celebration that starts today
happy new year by the way yes
and so the new year's celebration
involves you having a complete reset
you've got to reset what you're doing
you have a rethink you really do and
then you've got over and you got to
recommit
uh and so some of you have fallen off
the wagon or you said you know what i
made a couple decisions i wish i could
have changed
lesson 2020 is now behind us 2021 is
here
no more wishing and hoping for that year
to be done it's the new year's here
now what are you going to do tuesday
night you're going to be watching
the new reset event it's going to be
chris hogan
dave ramsey yep rachel cruz and craig
groschel
pastor craig now we're going to be over
at oklahoma city at their church doing
the event as a live stream
it's 100 free
and you can just watch it all you got to
do is text the word reset to 33789
and i was just like i just got an email
from pastor craig at the commercial
break and we're just we've been friends
a long time
back and forth kind of joking about it
picking on each other but uh we're
i'm looking forward to seeing him and
vice versa and uh we're gonna
spend some time together and then also
get to hear his incredible talk on
discipline rachel will be talking about
know yourself know your money and chris
and i are going to walk you through the
plan for your reset
how do you end up being the third pig
the guy in the brick house
not the one that gets his house blown
over by the big bad wolf
and last year the big bad wolf was
crawling around
yes he was and it was all over the place
and so i'm excited i'm very pumped uh
this is the first time
for the new year that dave rachel and i
will be on stage and the fact that you
get a chance to watch it for free
is awesome so again get your little
phone out text the word reset to three
three seven eight nine make it happen by
rsvp being your spot how do you know
they're a little fun they might have a
big phone well i was just saying a
little
little phone it's little to me i got big
hands who was the was the movie uh
zoolander they had the tiny little
phones you remember that that was
hilarious yeah
so oklahoma city if you're in that area
and you want to come to the reset event
that night there are a few seats
obviously it's spaced and very limited
but they're 20 bucks is all
and they're available at daveramsey.com
events and we do want a live studio
audience there
for the stream the stream is going to
have probably about a hundred thousand
folks watching it and it's completely
free
text to the word reset two three three
seven eight nine
to get registered and these are things
you need to do to get your new year
started off right stephen is with us in
san jose
hi stephen welcome to the dave ramsey
show
hey guys thanks for taking my call sure
how can we help
so i am looking to purchase my first
real estate uh property or my rental
sorry excuse me rental property
and unfortunately where i live it's very
expensive to purchase that so i was
wondering if you guys had any
advice or experience or maybe just
things to look out for when purchasing
out of state
well you do have a legitimate barrier
because you live in one of the most
expensive markets in america um
yeah i mean so silicon valley is um
unbelievable
price wise uh and it's not exactly a
rental market
um so i don't know how far you've got to
go away
here's the problem the further away from
you it is
that the property is the harder it is to
manage
and um i've had a lot of
friends and customers over the years
that have had really really bad
experiences
long-distance landlording to the point
that i don't own any property
that's not for rental purposes it's not
within a few miles of me
and um so yours may be more than a few
miles from you but i don't want you to
have something that's an airplane ride
away that's a good way to have a tenant
change their harley oil in your living
room
and uh you just you're just really tough
to manage well i can get a management
company well nobody
nobody cuts your grass like you do
nobody manages your property like you do
and so there are good management
companies there are bad ones without a
doubt
uh but you know you're gonna watch it
closer
even if you had a management company
you're gonna watch it closer if it's in
town
or near town near to you so i would
beg you to not buy long distance and
instead buy as close as possible
something in driving distance well and
that says a lot dave it's considering
how much property you own that it's
something that you would steer clear of
i mean that's enough said
um you know you you've got a man that
owns a lot of real estate
has been in the real estate market for
almost all of his life
and he's not going to buy so you know
you want to be smart about that if
you're out there and you're new in the
game
new into investing you want to do smart
moves that put you in the right spot
well when the kids started college at
university of tennessee in knoxville we
bought a condo over there
uh so we could stay there on the
weekends and see them and go to football
games and that kind of stuff and it sat
empty
a lot of the year and that kind of thing
they graduated from college and we
tended to go in and out for the football
game rather than stay over
and so the the thing was not being used
even two nights a year
right and i looked up and saw that um
about a year and a half ago and i did
something i almost never do
i sold a piece of real estate because my
choices were
rent the thing 250 miles away 200 miles
away
or and put up with the stuff that i'm
talking about um
or sell it and um and i almost once i
buy a piece of real estate i almost
never sell it
very unusual for me to sell property i
love real estate i'm careful
when i buy it and i keep it forever and
so i sold that condo
because otherwise i'd have been renting
a long distance and it just violates too
many things in my life
it makes my life too complicated right
and i don't want complicated no
so here you go people it's an investment
[Music]
experience 501 that's advanced
level right there this is the dave
ramsey chef
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
thank you for joining us america chris
hogan ramsey personality is my co-host
today michelle's with us in madison
wisconsin
hi michelle how can we dave hey help
how are you guys today great how can we
help
well i'm going to try to thumb this up
pretty quickly i've got a lot going on
over here but first of all i
have no debt um i was divorced last year
we sold our house um we bought it in a
session the recession
so um we got it cheap sold at the top of
the market kind of a
good deal as a bit of a deal as you can
get a divorce i guess
so have no doubt um i drive a paid off
subaru
no doubt whatsoever i'm happily renting
right now
um i've got some cheap living going on
at the moment
i have about uh 27
000 uh liquid savings so plenty of
emergency funds
um i do have several businesses
i'm actually selling one of them this
year i have an interested buyer so i'm
not sure how that's going to go
and i do have um half of my ex-husband's
function
um my question for you is what i should
be doing next
um i am not i don't earn
a lot um i do have five income streams
um which is a little unusual i think but
i'm able to be home with my kiddos who
are doing virtual schooling they're 15
13 and 11.
um my annual income is about 20 000.
uh i get about 500 a month in child
support
so my question is should i be saving for
my next home
or should i prioritize retirement and
education for the kids that are quickly
becoming adults
um if i'm happily renting is it
is it important to buy another house or
should i be prioritizing my money
elsewhere or all three
it's just a matter of which order it's a
matter of which not not all of them are
things you're going to get around to
it's just a matter of the order of the
attack you're still healing from a
divorce
you're trying to get a career started
again which apparently you probably
didn't have before
oh we did i have several i have um i
have several businesses actually there's
no but
not you're doing a lot of work for 20
grand yes
i am and so um i i think that's the
biggest thing that's a glaring concern
to me is your lack of income
yeah but the uh so no i wouldn't be
worrying about buying a home right now
i'd be worrying about
not worrying but my first order of
business is if i'm going to invest in
something
is to get your income up and that can be
a work at home
thing it could be that you invest some
money in one of these ideas that is
working and
that you can expand and i might do that
before i did i'm not worried about
buying a home immediately if you buy
home the next five years you'll be okay
yeah and and if you get the first kid in
college in the next five years you will
have done a good job
and so on but you're gonna have to have
income in excess of what you've got to
do either one of those things would you
agree
i do agree i am again i'm selling one of
my businesses this year
um how much does it sell for it's not
making any money
um yeah probably between
somewhere around 10 grand yeah and that
does not solve the issue
no at hand i mean you have a household
of four on 20 000 bucks
in madison wisconsin yes i know yeah
so that's the glaring that's the glaring
concern
i'm not saying you did something wrong
i'm just saying if there was an area to
work on it's not a lack of home
ownership
and it's not a lack of retirement
savings right it's the air the area we
want to work on is do something
and it could be investing into one of
these ideas again
if you're going to put money into
something that's what i would put it
towards
and not much but a little bit and let's
let's see if we could just
i mean really i mean you could double
your income maybe 40 000.
yeah and michelle you've done a great
job by not having debt
uh you've put yourself in a great
situation yeah and so
that's the thing i'm looking at because
again the income is going to allow you
to
be able to save up for a house or save
up for college and do the things you're
looking for so
again try to thin the herd a little bit
of the businesses yeah
and figure out which one's a hobby
versus which one's a business
uh because businesses make money hobbies
are fun and so just be honest with
yourself and start to assess that and
let go of some of those things
so now you can focus on the main things
and really be able to grow your income
i'm gonna guess and say out of the 20
000
15 000 comes from one of them
and the others are semi-hobbies probably
that have got
so they're a distraction and they
probably are fun
and she likes them ah but the one that's
making money she needs to lean in on i
think
wait a minute you said
and they enjoy it but it's a distraction
yeah meaning she's not making money
no hobby yeah no no yeah and that's
that's real
i'm just guessing yeah that's the way my
i'm a little bit add myself
and that's the way my mind works i can
get i can get caught up in 73 things at
once and i have to
purposefully go oh no we're going to get
the idea down to one or two
because i can get just i can get i can
thin out my resources so thin
right of time emotion spirit
money everything else is gone and so
hang on i'm gonna give you a copy of
chris
christie wright's book business boutique
uh equipping women to make money doing
what they love now i'm not saying having
fun is a bad thing i'm just saying
if you're not making any money doing it
and you're using fun as an excuse to do
it and calling it a business
that's a hobby yeah all right edwin is
with us edwin's in new york city hi
edwin how can we help
hi how are you thank you so much for
taking my call sure what's up
all right so um my wife and i we are on
a baby stead 3b
uh we're saving up for a house and um
we were debating also disabled for a car
as well
so we had some extra saving on the side
floor but we decided not to do it
and um my in-laws i guess they knew that
we wanted to get another car because i
already have one and my in-laws bought
my uh
my wife a car for her birthday so
we were very grateful and generous for
the gift and everything
but uh we found out that they actually
had to finance the car
in order to to get it to us so we
weren't really too comfortable with that
but um wanted to call to see what uh
what can we do next um
so obviously they did not put the car in
your name or they financed it with a
personal note
yeah well no they uh the car is under
their name yeah the insurance
registration everything's on their name
yeah um nothing's on power name
yeah and they still have to pay it off
and the other thing is it's a it's a
brand new car too
but it's not like an old car it's a
brand new car oh my
god um yeah so we don't want to
like we we have the money to we don't
know what the remaining balance is
well we could assume how much it is and
we have the money to
pay it but then they it feels
to them it feels like we're taken away
from their gift to us
yeah well this is not a gift this is a
curse
yeah they're just confused they're broke
people trying to do a nice thing
the wrong way and edward if you do this
you're taking money out of the home down
payment fund correct
well the thing is that we we so we had
the money aside
for that car and also for the home oh
okay but since we since we decided that
you know what we're not going to get a
call right now right we kind of just
grouped everything together
so the only difference is going to be is
i don't know a difference of like seven
months
in completing the babysitter 3d
so um that big of a deal for us but i
don't know
you've got you got serious family issues
right because normal people don't do
this this is toxic
normal people communicate adult to adult
and
say we'd love to give you a car but
we're going to take us a little while to
pay it off and talk about it
instead of showing up and going
surprised we're going to give you a pony
she's not eight years old she's a grown
woman
this is toxic weird crap yeah this tries
to tell us that hey look we want to get
your car what kind of car you guys want
and we told them like hey look you know
we want to wave we don't want to call
right now we're good how we are right
now
yeah i guess they just felt like it was
i don't know like they knew best kind of
thing
yeah they were demanding they they
decided they were gonna tell you all
what you're to do how does your wife
feel about this
uh she's a little mixed about it she she
doesn't want to hurt their feelings but
she knows it's a bad deal
right yeah exactly well i think the two
of you have to decide what you're going
to do
if this happened at my house your wife
is
it's her parents she's gonna have to
handle it i mean you can sit there for
support but she's gonna have to do the
talking
mom and dad we love you and this was an
attempt to do something really nice
but it was a negative attempt and we
don't want the car
we will not accept the car and you
should take the car
back and you should sell it and get it
out of your life and then you guys go on
with your life and don't do this again
please have better communication with us
than this this is not how we live our
lives
this is the dave ramsey
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters
with easy online ordering free shipping
and a guaranteed perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the air we're
answering your questions about your life
and your money
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five
maria is with us in tampa florida hi
maria welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave hi chris happy new year how are
you guys happy new year to you
we're great how can we help all right so
before i start i want to say
i feel very honored to be on the show
just because i've been listening to you
since i was a little girl
so um i turned to you for advice
um so i took on student debt
uh student loans to go to get through
college i'm the first in my family so i
feel
proud that i was able to accomplish that
and this year with the pin down like
that hit
uh it was a bit of a blessing and a
curse
um but with the stimulus and everything
um payments and interest got paused for
some time and now with the new
build that got post uh everything's
gonna start with
a payment full regime of interest um in
the meantime i saved up the money to
pay off the loan completely and i wanted
to
get your advice on should i
pay it off or should i maybe wait um
just to see kind of what happens are you
working
yes what do you make
um i make six figures
a little over 100k and you're old
26. where'd it go good job
thank you what do you do i
am a technology consultant in analytics
excellent
okay so how much is the student loan
debt
it is 21 000
and how much you have in savings
um i have about
25ish
and that's the money that i saved up for
the loan
and i kept it i kept it on hand just in
case
because i ran it was a very odd time
last year
um and then i i'm working towards baby
step number three
so that's what they were your major
experience
and your income is stable right now
right maria
yeah okay so guess what it's time to do
you have been diligent you've been
intentional you've saved this money up
to attack
uh this debt it's time to write that
check
it's time for you to not only to become
the first to go to college
but the first one to have it paid for
and
that's where you write that check be
ashamed to get that diploma
repo'd
yeah maria i'm gonna tell you something
i'm gonna i'm gonna give you some coffee
or red bull or something i need you to
get happy
i need you to get excited young lady
because not only are you working in your
career
and making a good living but you also
have a common sense
the stuff that dave's been teaching to
be able to save up to be able to set
yourself free from this student loan
this is a big deal write a check today
this is a big deal get online
and hit submit yes are you going to do
it
yes i am so once i hit submit i'm
officially that person i love it that's
where you're going to be
way to go over here that's where we're
at it's awesome
it's not the way i would have done it no
no but we got there that's right
and uh she is making six figures you
know what she's doing dave she's
resetting
now you know she's take she's getting a
reset and how many of you out there have
done some stuff you go boy i wish i
could back up and
redo this thing or fix it guess what
you've got an opportunity
with your money to be able to reset by
making new decisions
having a real plan that works and then
committing to sticking to it
yeah that's all you have to do that's it
so i mean if you
if you didn't get there the perfect path
nope you still got there
that's right and hit reset that's right
and now let's go forward
the shortest path on the right path
that's exactly right
yeah we can wherever you are in the
journey we can do that with you and
ramsey plus
has got a free offering right now for a
free trial and it's all about reset
so decide on a total money reset
for this year if you commit to working
hard in the first 90 days we will show
you exactly
step by step what to do for that first
90 days and you will go
wow for the first time ever i got
control of my money
because you will either manage money or
the lack of it'll manage you you don't
have a choice
you you have got to turn it you've got
to step into these lifelong habits
and change them and make them make this
money behave
it has to behave and only you can do
that
so ramsay plus our step-by-step plan
we've got a 90-day thing right now going
and you can get in there for a free
trial and get started you'll see how it
all works
and make sure that it's for you it
doesn't cost a thing just step in there
go to daveramsey.com
reset and chris is exactly right reset
reset reset reset
matt is with us in orlando hi matt how
are you
i'm fine thank you for taking my call
sure what's up
we've been listening to
you all for about three years prior to
that though we
incorporated into our portfolio some
whole life
insurance policies i'm sorry one policy
one policy has reached paid up status i
don't know
and the other one is um nearing paid up
status
has two more premium payments to go and
i was
wondering uh if you have some advice on
what i should do with these at this
point in time
or should i just leave them as is
well i'll cash them in if you've got the
proper amount of term insurance in place
it's not a place to invest money and
basically that's the status that it is
let me just tell you the idea that you
can pay off a life insurance policy
is a an impossibility statistically
the only thing you can do and they call
it paid up
but the only only thing you've done
there is you've overpaid and prepaid
so much that you've covered all the
actuarial costs of your death
the statistical probability of your
death the cost of insuring you is all
covered now
because you've given them so much
freaking money so far in advance
that it covers your whole entire life
now
and uh and it's now baked down into a
cash value
that you lose when you die and all
you'll get is
the uh well you won't get anything
you'll be dead but the only thing your
beneficiary will get is the face value
of the policy
and honestly the probably the lost
investment dollars on the cash value
would have bought your term insurance
more than you got in whole life right
now
i'm betting and i don't even know the
math on yours almost every one of them
i've seen
that if we took your cash value and
invested it at 10 it would pay for term
in perpetuation and that's what paid up
means it means you're just prepaid and
overpaid
so if you're healthy and can get term
insurance or have the proper amount of
term insurance in place
i wouldn't have this in my portfolio
it's the weakest part of your portfolio
personally if i woke up in your shoes is
how i answer these questions
what would i do knowing what i did no i
i
cancelled as fast as i possibly could it
is crap
and in your case it is double triple
crap
because you double triple paid yeah no
that's exactly right and again
if you don't have term in place get term
in place before you cash out anything
uh and as far as the whole life side so
get over there go to daveramsey.com uh
you can click on xander and we can help
you get term in place
goodness gracious probably worth a short
teaching segment on that then
so there's two kinds of life insurance
term and whole life
that's right a term you get whole life
you don't that's how to remember them
but the term is pure insurance all it
does all it covers is if you die you get
money
right and if you don't die you don't
give money right it's like homeowners
insurance
the only way you get money from your
homeowners or your car insurance is to
have a wreck or your house burns
that's right the the the event has to
occur it's pure insurance
and so it's a statistical average of
your death so the older you are
the more expensive it is and that's how
term that's how all insurance is based
it's the statistical average of the
event
it's a probability and statistics
equation
and it's called an actuarial table in
any type of insurance but in
term you're buying the insurance plus
profit plus commission
and the insurance company wants to pay a
commission and they want to make a
profit and so that's all that's in there
it's just pure uh or virtually pure
whole life is when they charge you 20
times more on average
literally that's not an exaggeration
five dollars of term
100 of whole life premium to buy the
same amount of coverage
that other 95 buys you a savings program
inside your policy called a cash value
build up that has a poor rate of return
and when you die they keep your money
this is why we tell you not to do it
this is why everyone tells you not to do
it
in the financial world except people
that sell whole life
they're the only ones that think whole
life is just dandy
it's crap it's the payday lender of the
middle class
i hope i wasn't unclear this is the dave
ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today isaiah 43 18 and 19
remember not the former things
nor consider the things of old behold i
am doing a new thing
now it springs forth do you not perceive
it
i will make a way in the wilderness and
rivers in the desert
[Music]
vernon mcclellan says what the new year
brings to you will depend a great deal
on what you bring to the new year
definitely
reshonda is with us in tucson arizona hi
richonda welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dude thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
so um i recently got some advice from my
financial advisor
that contradicts your advice
hello are you there
something happened rashonda are you
there
okay all we heard was your financial
advisor conflicted with our advice and
so
yeah that would just make them wrong
wrong okay and we're okay with that
sorry we'll put you on hold see if we
can get you back up there st george utah
terry's with us hi terry how are you
i'm well terry i'm well dave i'm a
little nervous sorry thank you for
taking my call
i've got myself into a mess and i get it
so you don't even have to yell
um know i know i listen to you
i know beans and rice and all of that
here's quickly
um and i can give you as much detail but
bottom line is
i just got a new job but i was without a
job for two years while i was finishing
my terminal degree
so now i'm a certified nurse midwife i
was a labor and delivery nurse
and they shut down the hospital in my
area
so i just kept doing my schooling so now
i'm done but i lived off student loans
and credit cards so i've got
44 000 in credit card debt 105 in
student loans
but i do own a home and but now i need
to
move because i i got a new job which is
going to pay me
89.4 a year wonderful um
that's the best news so far and i've got
people
right what's that what's the house going
to sell for
it's going to sell it's going to give me
at least 200k
in equity i also have a little rental
property part of it
so um i haven't put it on the market yet
so i i'm bottom line at least 200 it
could go as much as 230k
in equity so but i now have to move
great
closer because i'm now new job is three
hours away great
sell it pay off your debt what's wrong
with this plan done
oh not a problem except that i need to
have something to move into
so i was thinking about if i pay off my
credit card
am i i mean i need to have terry
my job terry rent
be debt free start fresh
yep you made a mess you have an
opportunity to clean it up in one fell
swoop
and you're going to have some money left
over yeah i mean only got 150 out of 230
you got
80 to put down on something if you
wanted to buy something
pay off all your debt don't monkey
around with this
okay and shut down the credit cards
terry
shut down the credit cards
um i signed up with um green path
financial wellness um and they got
i shut them down um the credit card
yeah but i if i pay it off then it'll
all be better now yeah you
you can't hand off the responsibility of
of the mess you created
so those management programs and all of
that that promise they'll handle it for
you
is tell them thanks but no thanks show
your house from payoff you're going to
pay it off and be done
and matter of fact don't even try to go
by go somewhere and rent for
three months now the biggest fear i have
of this whole thing
is that you next time you feel a little
bit scared or desperate because that's
what happened
here you won't hesitate to go back in
debt because you'll be debt-free and you
this time you won't have a household
so you have to raise your right hand and
swear never again am i going to use a
stupid credit card
never again am i going to say oh i was
forced to buy a car because my car broke
so i got car payments now
never again oh i had to go on vacation
oh my mother was ill so i had to buy an
airline ticket and i had no money
you can never say this crap ever again
you can never rationalize your way back
into debt because you get a clean slate
here
you got to take it and change your ways
permanently you have a 90 000
income you're a rock star you're going
to be in a place to go win
don't stupid's right around every corner
hogan says
waiting it's waiting i've got my right
arm my right arm is cute a square
and i promise because i hate this okay i
hate it well then be a hundred percent
free of it put 80
000 down on something after you rent for
six months in the new neighborhood
so you know the city well before you buy
and um go pile you up some money
make some money make some money have no
payments and i want you to get into
ramsey plus i'm going to give it to you
for a year
and i want you to go through financial
peace university and i want you to get
into the
every dollar budgeting app and i want
you to change the way you've viewed
money emotionally because money's been
telling you what to do your whole life
and now you're about to tell it what to
do okay
you got it how do i get in to the
financial piece uh we're in the ramsey
plus we're gonna give it to you i'm
gonna put you on hold and kelly's gonna
pick up we got you taken
yeah and terry i also want you to dive
over and watch us on the reset event on
january 12th
there you go yes rashanda is in tucson
reshawn is short on time now let's try
again how can we help
um i got some advice from a financial
advisor that contradicts your advice
so i wanted to get your opinion well i
would my opinion would be they would be
wrong
why would i change my opinion
right so my husband and i wanted to pay
off our house
really quickly because our interest rate
is super low it's only 2.75
and our financial advisor said that it
would be better
to make that money plus on with the 19
percent
gain on our investments did you say a 19
gain that's what we got this year we
know that's not the normal oh
yeah yeah yeah they might have this year
but he didn't say he didn't he didn't
project that for you i hope because he
go to jail
okay the uh uh so here's the thing chris
hogan is sitting next to me did a book
called everyday millionaires
we studied 10 000 millionaires
you know how many of them said they
became millionaires by the strategy that
your investment advisor told you
zero zero
oddly enough the av they did two main
financial things that made them their
first one to five million
you know what they were chris first of
all
first and foremost they invested in
401ks 403bs
roth iras and iras the second thing they
did rashanda is they paid off their
homes
and right at 10 years now these were 10
000 millionaires not a financial advisor
not one of them became a millionaire
by not paying off their home and using
the money
to invest and making the spread not one
of them
isn't that interesting it is so it's not
like
my opinion versus his it's like
all the data says he's wrong and the
reason is is that a paid off home
sets you free in so many ways
emotionally spiritually mathematically
everything else to be able to go on and
live your life in a way that you can
invest when you when you have a paid off
home
and you have um a hundred thousand
dollars less in your investments and a
pandemic hits
you don't have the same feeling as you
do when all that money is in investments
and your home is not paid off in a
pandemic hits
oh and the market goes down and you're
scared to death watching the news at
night
i wasn't scared watching the news at
night
i was sad for some people that were
scared
but i wasn't scared is that because i'm
stuck up or arrogant
no it's because i don't have any debt
and i got a pile of money
it's a pretty simple equation it really
is one year financial advisor should
adopt
yeah and rashad here's the deal you know
the fact you know the reality
what you do when you bump into stupid is
you just smile at it and
there's a phrase we say here in the
south bless your heart
but what you do is you continue to move
on your path
yeah and you move on from this financial
advisor to one that's not trying to make
money he ended up making commission when
you pay off your house
i mean that's just it's just wrong yeah
so i mean
i i understand but they're leaving at
you're leaving out risk
and when you put risk in the
mathematical formula it does away with
the perceived returns
and the investment world is not a lot of
the folks haven't figured that out in
that world
and it's it's just a wrong and again the
data
of people who actually built wealth
backs up what we're saying but you do it
you can do whatever you want to
it's all good hey thanks for the call
open phones that puts us our
dave ramsey show in the books thanks to
james and to kelly in the booth i am
dave ramsey we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace christ jesus
[Music]
[Music]
you